Next up, we'll talk about arrays.
So just with the variable values, blueprints can store data within arrays.
So if you're not versing programming, you can think of an array as a collection of variable
all housed within a single unit.
So whereas a single integer was just able to store one number, an array of integers
would be able to store multiple values.
So an array can only hold values of a single type.
So if we've created an integer, you can only hold integers in here.
And array variables will contain 3 by 3 color grid, which is what you can see in the image
here to show that they are arrays and not regular variables.
So in the case of a disconnected array, that gray will have a darker center.
So once centered, once connected, sorry, the entire grid will be visible as seen below.
And then to create them, we can just click on this variable icon, drop down to array.
So let's go ahead and add some more functionality to our camera switch mechanic now.
And once back in the editor, I can full screen this window again, drag it up to the top.
And let's create an array from this switch here.
So instead of flip flop in between the two, now let's try creating an array of cameras
to view our lens through.
So I'm just going to remove the flip flop for now.
I'm just going to click it and delete it.
I'll just be focusing on this one view target for now.
And instead of connecting to a single camera, I'm going to hold down alt and disconnect
this camera ref one.
I am just going to drag it over here.
I'm going to hold down alt on camera ref two and just drag it over there as well.
You can also just right click and break links if you need to break a link.
Now what we'll do is we will make an array from these cameras.
So I'm going to drag out of this camera.
I'm going to do make array.
So let's just try array.
So you just want to select make array there.
Drag that into place.
And we want to add a pin.
So I'm going to use maybe three or four different cameras for this.
So let's just add pin, add pin, add pin.
I'm going to drag this into here.
And now let's create a few more, well, two more camera reference.
So camera ref three and then camera ref four.
I'm going to make sure I categorize these into the cameras.
Again not necessary, but it just helps keep things organized.
And you want to make sure you click the little i to expose them as public variables.
So I'll compile and save.
And then the first thing I'll do is I'll just create a couple more cameras.
So I'll maybe create a top down shot here.
So pilot.
I'll eject here.
I'll just rename this.
Top down bushes.
And then maybe just do an extreme close up for some reason other than non practical purposes.
So it's even out of focus, but extreme close up bushes.
And I'll also click my dinosaur head.
And then I'll select my top down camera as my next camera.
And I'll select my extreme close up as my next camera.
So got four camera references, four cameras assigned.
Now we can jump into doing the array.
So I'll go back into my camera switch.
I've made my array.
I can drag out these references holding down control on my keyboard.
I'll just copy and paste these resolves.
Not with extra variable selected, so just variable copy and paste, copy and paste, which
is just control C, control V on the keyboard.
Drag out here.
We've got our array connected up.
So you should see something like that.
Then what we'll do is on the array, we'll get.
So we'll get a copy.
So what this get will do is it will say from this list of cameras, get a specific variable.
So what we want to do is we want to promote this one now to get camera.
So I'll drag off here, promote it to a variable and I'll call it get camera.
And now this is actually an integer and we want it to be an integer.
So that's fine.
And I'm just going to give it a category of cameras.
So it keeps things nice and organized still.
Now because we're getting a specific camera reference, we can say new view target is this
one.
That will actually say, depending on the list of what you want to do, you can get a specific
camera from this list.
So if I put this in here and I tested it out and I said, say I wanted to expose this, get
cameras, compile and save.
And you could say in your blueprint, get camera two, for example, and it would only display
camera two.
So that's pretty powerful functionality in itself.
And so let's just test that out.
Let's do, let's connect this in.
Let's do this.
Compile, save.
I'll click number two on here and it'll set a specific camera for us when we hit the hash
key.
So there you go.
It's got camera two from the list, which is our top down camera.
Just worth noting in mind, camera ref three is our top down camera.
Number two, you might be thinking that it should have been the close up.
Now, a thing to note about arrays is that it actually starts at zero.
So it goes zero, one, two, three.
So if it helps name things in your head more clearly, if you put camera ref zero, camera
ref one, two and three, that's fine.
But in case your integers are off by one, that'll be why, because arrays start at zero.
If we go back into our camera switch, you'll see make array is zero, one, two, three.
That's just something to keep in mind there.
And then finally, we'll talk about multi gate cameras.
So instead of using an array, we can use a multi gate, which is essentially just a flow
of information.
A gate will choose which camera to set.
So I'm just going to hold down alt and drag out, move this into its own space.
We'll be using multiple set view targets again.
So I'll keep that here.
I'm just going to copy and paste that third view target just so we have more to play with.
And I'm just going to drag that into the target just so we can see that happening.
I'm just going to get organized here.
So what we want to do is we want to add a multi gate node now.
So we'll type in multi and we'll select the multi gate from the list.
We'll add a pin.
So we've got out zero, out one, out two.
And we'll just select these two, the desired cameras, the desired view targets, shall we
say.
And then I'm going to copy and paste the camera references that we had before and just plug
them into their respective view targets.
So again, you can drag out each variable individually if you wanted.
I'm just going to copy and paste them since we have them from the previous example.
And then what we want to do is after we've plugged them all in, create a switch camera
from the loop.
So if we drag off the loop here and then we want to promote it to a variable, we can call
this switch cam.
Again, I'll just keep it in its category so we know what this is.
And then we want to create a scene switch from this float value here.
So I'll drag off again from the index and we'll promote this to a variable and we'll
call this scene switch and I'll assign it a category again and then compile and save.
And then I'll expose these just as we had before just in case we need extra functionality
And we could do our event.
Instead of cameras, we could try assigning multiple categories.
Could even call this something like multigate.
And so I know that these variables are connected to the multigate just in case that separation
is of use to you.
And then we just want to compile and save.
So we can do that and then we'll jump into our level.
Once you've saved and compile, you'll see that the multigate heading is here.
So we've not got switch cam or we've not got scene switch set.
So we can again use that blend time if we wanted to between the cameras.
If we just go ahead and set this actually, let's set this to a value of one, value of
one, value of one.
We can use a blend time for motion between cameras.
So we could even just test that out in this example.
So if I hit Alt and P now and press hash, we then pan to that one and then we go to
the next target and then we go to the next one.
But now if I press hash again, it's not going to work because what we did was the switch
cam was not ticked, which if I go into here and I go into my multigate, the loop was not
ticked.
I can do this loop as well, but call it switch cam for now.
But if we want to tick switch cam, which I'll do in here.
And again, you saw the blending, which was a good example of the camera blending as well.
But if we hit hash, first camera, second camera, third camera, and then back to the start as
well, which is a really nice, powerful functionality.
And then you've also got the start index where, you know, if we wanted to start one, for example,
compile and save.
And again, we could have changed that on the actual actor as well.
If we hit Alt and P, we hit hash, we can start at a specific part of the chain.
So we're starting here on the second camera, third camera, back to the first one, second
one, et cetera.
So multigates again, pretty powerful functionality.
If you're trying to have multiple outputs, you can start at a specific index and you
can also keep looping through.
And we could add things like re-triggerable inputs where it's just constantly firing.
But hopefully all of these different examples just gave you a good idea about Blueprint
and the functionality that you can have when working inside these tools.